- Hey good humans.
Welcome to Middle Ground.
Keep an eye out for an interactive
prompt in the middle of
this episode and thank you for watching.
- [Interviewer] Step forward if you agree.
Our generation is misinformed.
(footsteps)
- I do feel our generation is
heavily misinformed sometimes
because of social media.
A lot of the times they just see movements
as sort of a trend
without looking into them.
And I feel that that happened so much
they'll just go with it.
And I feel like a lot of the
times it makes it very easy for
us to kind of just be
tailed by the government.
And I feel that we need
to do a lot better job
at looking into things and really reading
into things and starting to
take facts over feelings.
- Yeah, because it's 10 times easier
to just look at something
and accept it as truth
than to go and do your
research and find counterclaims
or something that aligns with that.
Because if you're just sitting
there and look like scrolling
through TikTok than somebody
says that this is happening,
I mean, like who's gonna?
It's not really...
- Educate yourself.
- Yeah.
- I strongly agree with both of you guys.
You know, I think the
reason why I was hesitant
about walking over is even though I agree
that our generation is misinformed,
that doesn't mean that older generations
aren't also misinformed
especially, you know,
in the form of for like
Gen X and the baby boomers
or whatever.
Cable news in particular, you
have millions of Americans
now who are tuning in every night
to see Tucker Carlson
spread misinformation.
I don't wanna pick on him in particular,
but he's an example.
Social media is just another
example of what's been going
on for generations and
generations of people,
just with all due respect
being too lazy to do their own
research and just believing
what other people tell them.
- Yeah. So I completely
agree with you guys,
but I also wanted to add that
as a generation we don't have
good examples of politicians
and how they disagree and agree anymore.
When my parents were younger,
they used to watch the
politicians in the Senate
in the house have like
great lively debates
and come to a conclusion in the end
and you would see how they were speaking
and how they bounced off
each other's opinions.
And now that we don't
have that example anymore,
we're forced to get our
information from social media.
And a lot of the news channels these days
are heavily biased.
And because of that, I
feel like as a generation
we're heavily misinformed.
My dad and I spoke to each
other a lot about politics
and since I was a liberal at that time
and he was a conservative, we
would have a lot of debates.
I would find myself growing
and becoming more moderate just
because the things he said
and the things I listened to
and the things I researched
because of points
that he made to me,
I would find myself transitioning
into more of a moderate.
- [Interviewer] All right, can
the disagreers step forward?
- I disagreed because in 2022,
truth is becoming less and less objective
and more and more subjective.
And there will always be objective truth,
but humanity will stray
further and further from that,
especially when a lie can
be attached to an emotion.
You see, we are thinking
less and less critically
and more and more emotionally as a whole.
And so when you see
something like for instance,
George Floyd May of 2020,
that just strikes your heart.
First thing you wanna do,
go to Instagram post a black
square. Now what is that doing?
I don't quite know,
but what it made you feel was
like you did something to help
that poor fellow who got a terrible thing
that happened to him.
- When I was hearing this question,
I was thinking like is the
majority of like my generation,
AKA the people I know, misinformed?
And I would definitely say yeah,
I feel like the lack of
information is like almost
as bad as like receiving,
the wrong information.
- I wanna touch up on something you said.
I think it is true that
social media did change
the way we receive information,
whether that is
misinformation or the truth,
but that doesn't make us
misinformed because of that.
Obviously like yes you have social media,
it's so much easier to get information,
but I don't think because
we have social media
that automatically makes you misinformed.
(dramatic music)
(gentle music)
- [Interviewer] My parents
influenced my political beliefs.
- I grew up in a conservative
Christian household in Iowa.
So I'm very, very well around
like conservative politics
all the time.
And my parents have absolutely
influenced like not only
my morals but my political
beliefs through that manner.
And I think a lot of those
teachings actually led me
to being more progressive and
more liberal over time rather
than actually being conservative.
- Yeah, for me it's kind of similar.
My dad is Christian but in
Vietnam they have this thing
where actually like they practice
both Buddhism and Christianity
From both religions, both
Buddhism and Christianity,
it's always taught about
like we as a community need
to take care of each other.
We need to respect each other and we need
to create like the best society we can.
My parents not like
directly telling me like,
Oh you should believe this
or you should believe that,
but just the way that they
have taught morals to me
and also their own personal experiences
have influenced my own beliefs.
In Buddhism is basically, what can you do
that is the best for others.
Of course not everyone
agrees with my beliefs,
but regardless of that I still want them
to have happiness in life.
- I'd say my parents gave me probably one
of the most interesting
childhoods out there.
I was observant, so I watched my community
and when I saw how things had progressed
in my community and then
sort of just stopped,
especially during the housing recession
and crash in 2007 and eight,
I had a deep question as
to why aren't things getting better?
They didn't teach me anything,
they let me learn my
own way because if they
had taught me something I wouldn't have
had the thirst to know more.
- [Interviewer] So why
did you step forward?
- I stepped forward because
I believe without them
I could have had some,
some other sort of beliefs,
but I felt that what they taught
me pushed me down my path.
- So I became a conservative in 2018
and I became that based off my research.
I was actually a liberal before that just
because everyone else
around me was a liberal.
I would vote for Trump
in the upcoming election
over Biden, over anyone
else that runs against him.
He embraces free market
economics, just like I do.
We need less government
spending, we need to cut taxes,
we need to cut government spending.
And Donald Trump would definitely do that.
- Are your parents conservative?
- They are actually.
But politics never came up in my family
before Trump became president.
So they did not influence
me to be a conservative.
- But, there were two
years in between, you know,
Trump being inaugurated in 2017
and then if it was like late
or mid 2018.
- Yeah,
- about a year and a half of
Trump being in office running
headlines, a lot of big things happening.
Are you sure none of
that and their commentary
at the dinner table
maybe didn't influence?
- No, I remember 2016
election they didn't say
a thing about who they wanted.
- That's hard. That's hard.
- I know, I'm telling you,
it just didn't come up.
And obviously this country's
way more political now than it
was 10 years ago, but I'm telling you,
I just became conservative
based off my own research.
- Our whole entire family
is very much on the left
like democratic liberal.
But my mom, she was
not and she would claim
that she was a Republican
but I don't think she knows a damn thing
about what that means.
(laughing)
But like she..
- Shots fired.
- (laughing) Right?
But there was a lot of tension
a lot whenever we would talk
about certain political
things that I would bring up.
And then my brother,
he's very right-leaning.
One day I like came
home and they were going
through like a journal of
mine that was like just
of like my liberal views
and like black Lives matter,
stuff like that.
And then I realized in
that moment I was like,
we aren't on the same page
and I don't think we ever
are going to be.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] Moderates
are the solution.
(footsteps)
- Pretty straightforward.
This country functions best when people
from all different walks of life,
all different political ideologies
are able to come together
for a greater cause.
I believe that the two
party system is a trap.
I believe that political
parties as a concept
are antithetical to democracy.
- Yeah, I completely agree with you.
And I also just wanted to add that I think
both parties are a lot
more radical than they used
to be and I think moderates
are helping bridge
that gap in between and kind
of showing that you know,
you can agree with both parties
which can help especially in
you know, Senate and
House of Representatives
to come up with better
policies and to come up
with better laws that help
our people instead of you know,
the bickering that we see among
our politicians right now.
(footsteps)
- I just think the problem in America is
that we don't have
enough political parties,
we only have two.
That's the problem.
It makes us so divided that we
have to pick between the left
or the right.
- Yeah. Also, I hate this notion
that it's always like what's
in the middle that's right.
I think really we should
be looking at whether
it's right or not.
Not necessarily based upon
the fact whether it's right or
whether it's left or
whether it's in the middle.
It should be based upon the arguments,
it should be based upon
the rationalization.
- I love your take on that.
But nothing can really ever
be right because what's right
to one person is not gonna
be right to the next.
- I mean you can look ideologically
at both and I can say,
well this is this and this is this.
But who's to say which is correct?
Which is why the problem of parties
I think can't really be
solved by breaking the binary.
It's something that is in
ingrained into us as humans
to be team members, to be competitive.
Competition is what we
are even when it comes
to representing ourselves,
leading ourselves and
attempting to better ourselves.
So having more teams isn't gonna fix that.
- Well why not just
eliminate the political party
just to achieve, you know,
the ability of people to
cooperate with each other.
Because George Washington
warned of political partisanship
in his farewell address.
He wasn't saying we need more parties.
He was saying we need no parties
because these political
parties force people
to believe a certain way just
so that they can fit in with
their fellow party members.
- Well Thanos snapping away
the party system isn't going
to get rid of ideological teamsmanship.
- Exactly.
- We are always going to have
these issues and every person,
whether they've got a D or
an R next to their name,
they're gonna get, or I say,
hey, are you pro or anti-abortion?
Okay, get into this.
Are you pro or anti-gun?
You might see some of these
groups slightly different,
but in the scheme of things,
we're still going to have these teams,
even if we have it split up
into a million different parties
like some of these parliaments
and other countries do.
What do those parties do when they need
to get something done?
They form blocks, they form coalitions,
which is basically just
reducing it back to the binary.
We are still going to have
these binary teams because that
is just the way humans work.
- So you think politics should
embrace the binary system.
- Well, but the whole point of what
you were saying about how
you should make decisions
based on individual policy ideas,
like are you pro-choice? Are you pro-life?
If parties are eliminated,
people will actually be
forced to do research
on the politicians who believe in ideas
that are closest to theirs.
- The kind of extreme either
lefts or even right people,
you know, they kind of
just slap a label on it.
And I feel like moderates do
a lot of their own research
because they don't necessarily
agree with one side.
So every problem that comes up,
they have to go and do their
own research about it to figure
out what side they agree with
or what opinion they have on it.
- [Interviewer] So why did you
not agree with the problem?
- I do think that
sometimes having, you know,
maybe different groups
provide conversation
and if we were all the same thing,
it's not necessarily we're
not gonna have any progress.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] Neither Trump
nor Biden are good presidents.
(footsteps)
- My family benefited from a lot
of President Trump's policies,
but basically what I felt
was that a president needs
to be presidential and
for President Biden,
I just think that personally
he's too old to be president.
I do think there needs
to be a cutoff limit
when someone can be president.
- Yeah, young people are
heavily unrepresented
within our country.
The average age of an American
is around 37 years old,
whereas people in Congress are generally
above the age of 50 on average.
So when people kind of point
at Biden to be very old,
Trump's also extremely old too.
So if we wanna put some type
of age limit on that side,
I think that they're both
way too old to be president.
And obviously we need a
lot more representation
for younger people.
- Neither of them seem to
have been particularly popular
even within their own parties.
Trump to a lesser extent.
- Well Trump was extremely
popular amongst his party,
whereas Biden has actually
lost a lot of that popularity
throughout time as people have seen him
throughout his presidency.
I think there were a lot of
things on both the Republican
and Democratic side in which
these particular figures led
to like a larger amount of
polarization amongst the public.
(footsteps)
- I don't like Trump because
of a lot of the racist things
that he has said and if
you're out making jokes
about, oh I'm gonna build a
wall and even if it was serious,
that's not something to joke about.
And it seems like it's
very targeted towards
one specific group.
- Joe Biden has a much
stricter racist history
than Donald Trump ever has and
in my opinion ever will have.
During the 2019 presidential
cycle, Joe Biden said,
if you even think about voting for anybody
other than me, you ain't black.
And when I learned about the atrocities
that the Democrat party had done,
not just to the world and to America but
to my race specifically,
it's told me something that
I could never in my opinion
be a Democrat and it would be,
it would take a lot to even vote for one.
And on top of that, back in the eighties,
he was responsible for, as he
said, he wrote the dang bill,
the Clinton Crime Bill,
which was responsible for
throwing a lot of people
that look like us in
prison. This guy is weird.
- I mean within your statement
you didn't necessarily
acknowledge any of the racist history
in relation to Trump as well.
So if your' only gonna put eyes on like
either Trump or Biden, I
see that not necessarily
to be like the most consistent framework
for looking at this.
- Of course and I
understand why you say that,
but she didn't actually provide
any examples of a history.
She provided a media
mismanagement of what he said
in 2015/16 talking about immigration.
But every time Trump
tries to talk about this,
they call him a racist and a xenophobe.
- I come from a family
that is of immigrants,
my grandparents don't speak
English and they are from Mexico
and a lot of the time
people were bashing Trump
for that being a racist thing.
He's trying to keep them
out but he's only trying
to keep the criminal
individuals such as you know,
drug lords or people sending
drugs to our country.
- At the same time though,
it's sort of like disingenuous
to say that you know,
the immigration policies are
just keeping the bad people out
because at the same time
it's almost impossible
for most people to immigrate
to the United States legally.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] Billionaires
can solve problems
better than the government.
(footsteps)
- Capitalism will always
be more superior than
the public sector in
almost like 90% of things
in this country.
Billionaires have obviously
they have a lot of money,
but what I see is that
billionaires are using their money
for philanthropy, they
don't want to pay taxes.
I see that because they just
feel like if the government
takes their money they're not
gonna do good with the money.
A great example be Amazon.
I mean it has revolutionized
the way we shop.
- I think the key word in the
prompt is billionaires can,
you know, affect positive change
better than the government.
I don't think it's a like
guarantee that they will
cause I think there are certain instances
of billionaires doing
good with their money,
but then there are also, you know,
I know you mentioned Jeff Bezos,
but he also often doesn't
use his money for good
because there are many
reports of Amazon employees
being mistreated, denied
breaks and you know issues
where it's like, come on,
you have all that money.
Do you need like so much more
from like cutting corners like that.
- These billionaires
can do fantastic things
but I also understand that
government regulations,
taxes and various other
things occupied their time.
I don't believe billionaires
should be heavily taxed.
I believe the tax cuts
we had in 2018 were some
of the best things we saw for our economy.
- I completely would agree with you
that we shouldn't be taxing billionaires
at such a high rate.
If you tax billionaires, they
would respond by increasing
the prices of goods and services.
I think the reason why everything is
so expensive is inflation.
But in the past when inflation
was low there were times
where things were very
expensive and that is because
of the fact that we have
high corporate tax rates
in some states.
- Well so I respectfully disagree
with the idea that taxing billionaires
or specifically leaving
billionaires untaxed
is beneficial to the American economy
because the
most like prosperous era
for the American economy was the 1950s,
the post-war economic miracle.
That was when billionaires
were being taxed
at a rate of 90%.
And this isn't socialism or anything,
this was under American capitalism
under a Republican
president, Dwight Eisenhower.
- And this was right after a fantastic,
I hate to say fantastic war
but it was a fantastic war
for us in which we got
so much American pride
and that Republican president, Dwight,
Dwight D. Eisenhower then
utilized that money that he taxed
from those billionaires
to create a great system
which is the interstate system,
which is a fantastic thing
that connects our country.
But unfortunately the government isn't
really investing money in
things like that anymore.
It's investing money in
weird programs and things
that the average American
isn't going to benefit from.
- So billionaires do have a lot of money
and a lot of influence in order to do good
within our economy.
But nowhere near the
ability of the government,
if we're talking about
billions of dollars,
the government has access
to trillions of dollars
on a federal scale like yearly speaking.
Yeah, in some circumstances
like Mark Cuban,
they absolutely can do those things.
It doesn't anywhere near
compare to the level of access
of healthcare that they do
have in these other countries.
- And it doesn't compare to the damage
that will happen to the average American
when the government decides
to pull trillions of dollars
out of nowhere.
Cause we have to remind
ourselves the government makes
nothing, the government takes
from every single citizen
standing in this room that
pays taxes each and every day
including state governments
and federal governments.
They start throwing trillions
at random things like
I don't know, healthcare for everybody
which can work for a
country that's the size
of maybe South Carolina but will not work
for the size of our country.
- Yeah I would say that's because
our government actually like mismanages
with money comparative to other nations.
We spend a lot
- That's true.
- in terms of our per capita on healthcare
like more than other countries.
Yet they actually have
better health outcomes
and they cover more people.
So I do think there are
lots of things that the
United States could do better comparative
to other countries.
We can learn a lot more
from those other countries
and yet we don't do that
because of this idea
of American exceptionalism.
- When you were talking about
like how it's much easier
to like manage like a
country that's smaller,
that's completely true.
Like whatever the national
government does doesn't really
affect me and that's why like for me
I'm a very strong participant
in my own local government
cuz you can like actively
go there and talk
about like what you want things to budget
and it allows you to actually
see tangible effects.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] The Supreme
Court is out of touch.
(footsteps)
- The Supreme Court is
full of older people,
which is why I just feel like if we were
to bring some newer
fresher justices in there,
they would understand
what we're seeing more.
Because as an older person,
yeah you can do your research
but you won't experience
things the way that we are
experiencing them at this moment.
- Yeah, I agree.
And also the original
intention of the Supreme Court
was to be a nonpartisan, strictly legal
governing body.
Anything is contingent
now on how many people
on the Supreme Court
have Rs next to their,
next to their names and how many people
have Ds next to their names.
(footsteps)
- I don't think the Supreme
Court makes decisions
based off what society wants.
They make decisions based
off what the law says.
The Supreme Court is a
non-political branch.
- I so disagree with that.
The executive branches
and legislative branches
weren't really necessarily
created to be political either.
They were created to
create laws so that we
could live moral and just lives.
The Supreme Court and the
judicial branch as a whole
is something that was
created to be nonpartisan.
But unfortunately that's not
realistic in 2022 anymore.
And that's why I don't say
they're out of touch because
we're all out of touch and if
everybody's out of touch then
we're all in touch. Right?
- Well not necessarily
it would just mean all
of us are out of touch.
- If you look at the
foundation of this country,
there were political parties
within the executive branch
and the legislative branch.
There were no political parties
in the Supreme Court, never.
- Yeah, yeah.
So like in terms of the founding fathers,
they were heavily against
political parties.
I think the process outside
of the Supreme Court
of how we determine Supreme
Court judges is like
the messed up process, not necessarily
the Supreme Court in of itself.
- I just think that we
should never politicize
the Supreme Court.
- Really the best thing
we can do in the situation
is try to make general
public a lot more a part
of the process of determining whether
or not these justices should
be in that place based upon
not only their merit
but also like the things
they're advocating for.
But rather than it being
based upon like specifically
the political parties,
we need a multi-party democracy
so that multiple
different sides are looked
at different times and say
I wanna pick a libertarian
or I wanna pick a social
democrat or a socialist
or a liberal, right?
There are lots of different
options that we should have
in order to have more of
a competitive political marketplace.
- But wouldn't it make it more political
for the people to choose their judges?
- Yes, absolutely.
- I'm pretty sure we do vote in the people
that pick the Supreme Court justice.
- You vote for the president.
- We vote for the president.
(inaudible crosstalk)
- Also not necessarily
like jurisprudential
or like law in particular.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] I'm hopeful
about my future in this country.
(footsteps)
- Here in the United
States we have the ability
and the opportunity to be the best nation
in the world and live up to all the ideals
that we grew up with
and thought that we had.
Look at all of us, we're
willing to have a conversation
whereas years ago we
might not have sat down,
we might have hated each other
for having different types
of beliefs.
So I really think that shows
the type of growth potential
that the United States has in particular.
- I personally think I have a
great future in this country,
especially being a woman
because I can sit here
and wear what I want,
say what I want and
have just as many rights
and equal facilities as you
do as in other countries
that's not awarded to all
women or even all people.
And I feel that our country gives us some
of the most privilege in the world.
- So for me right now,
I live a great life.
I have a house, I have a cat,
I have two dogs and it's great.
But I feel like things could
always be better, you know?
And I think that's what
I like about this country
is that we have a government where
we can actively participate in
and we can make the changes
that we want to see.
- I think that I am very
scared for my future.
I grew up two hours away from
a Ku Klux Klan headquarters.
If that tells you anything
about where I grew up,
there's probably less
than the amount of fingers
I have on my hands of people
of color in my school.
There was a lot of racial
heat that I got growing up
and it forced me to grow up a lot faster
than I thought that I'd have to.
Cause if you look up Harrison, Arkansas,
it's known as one of the most
racist cities in America.
And you can see if you're on
TikTok and you see we visited
the most racist city in America,
that's gonna be Harrison, Arkansas.
My mother is white.
But whenever my mom would
drive through Harrison when we
were going somewhere,
she would put a blanket
over my crib while we were
in that city just because
she felt unsafe for me.
And whenever I hosted the
Black Lives Matter protest,
a lot of members from that
Ku Klux Klan organization
in Harrison were making groups saying
that they were gonna come up
and harass us and harm us.
And it's a very scary thing
because you read about
the Ku Klux Klan in history books.
It's a very different thing to
hear them personally tweeting
out to you that they're gonna come
and that they're gonna harm you.
As much as our country is growing,
I'm also not gonna invalidate
the fact that there is
a lot of issues that are
still stemmed very deep
in a lot of people's brains that are still
being acted out upon and
causing me to feel uncomfortable
to live in my country.
- As a black woman.
I just feel like being
anywhere in the world,
it's not just America.
There will always be somebody
who does not like a person
of color and there will
always be someone who wants
to assault a woman.
We are making progress,
but in the same way
we can always go backwards.
In Detroit, I just was not happy.
Being around white kids at school,
I don't think they,
I think they are taught to
believe that black people
are maybe lower than them
and even if it's not taught,
it's something ingrained just in society.
- As someone who is not, you know,
quite as dark as you but lives
kind of a similar lifestyle.
I'm trying to say is that
I understand, I really do.
It's still a thing that
can be stronger than ever,
especially with the
benefit of social media.
I think it's something that
we need to grow past if we're
going to make the world
better for our children.
But I think we're also right here,
which is a very diverse
group in and of itself.
But I think we're gonna
be one of the least racist
generations ever, which
kind of goes without saying.
And I think this will be the
century that that is just
completely eradicated,
at least systemically.
- Well I hope you're
right and it obviously
is a privilege to live
in the United States,
but I think we're going
down a very dangerous path.
Freedom of speech is under
attack in this country.
Freedom of thought is under attack.
The standard of living has
decreased dramatically.
People are, are just,
aren't doing better today
than they were 10 years ago
or 20 years ago.
- What do you mean we're
doing worse off now?
Like what are you looking at in terms
of how did you determine whether
or not we're doing worse off?
- Well there's so many things to look at.
One of it is how divided
we are politically.
But at the end of the
day we are the future.
- That is true.
- I hope that we don't
follow what they're doing.
I hope that when our
generation goes into Congress,
I hope that we're not
so politically divided
as they are now.
- One thing that gives me a lot of hope
is just like all of us
right now here talking,
we're all from different backgrounds.
We've all had different
stories in our past,
but we're all here and we're
all having a conversation
and we're all listening to each other.
We're all getting our ideas
out. And in the end of the day,
I think this is giving
me hope for the future
cuz this is what's gonna change.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] Most of my friends have
the same political beliefs as I do.
(footsteps)
- I came from a very
conservative and republican city
and state in Arkansas and
I grew up around a lot
of people who did not have
the same beliefs as me at all.
And a lot of the people
that I would try to keep
in my circle who did
have different beliefs
were blasting me on private
stories and stuff like that
and making me feel like I was dumb.
- It's really hard for me to make friends
that are from the liberal
side as immediately they hear
or even see my political
views or even my religion,
they immediately try to shut me down.
They send me death threats.
They put stuff in my bag
saying they're gonna kill me.
They've poured paint in
my bag and shaken it up.
When COVID happened and things
were starting to shut down
and the incident with
George Floyd happened,
everybody started looking
through everyone's profiles,
their family's profiles,
especially when these
protests were going on.
And there was a picture
of my dad and my family,
all of us together, and he
was wearing a Trump shirt.
I was getting a lot of death threats,
a lot of encouraging me to commit suicide,
threatening to do unspeakable things to me
and my family, threatening to
find my address and hurt them.
I could in fact say almost
all of them were liberals.
It's makes it really,
really hard because the minute
that you're different from
them, at least in my experience,
they shut you down immediately.
So I just kind of close
myself off and I stay friends
with the people that
are going to respect me
and respect my views.
- When I came out publicly
as a conservative in 2018,
it was probably one of the hardest years
I've ever went through.
At my school, having my opinions
while looking like I did was a nonstarter.
I received so many
obviously negative messages.
They called me some terrible things,
which I don't even
think I can say on here.
But all the phrases that
you've heard, you know,
get thrown at black conservatives simply
for having their ideas
and make it look like
I'm some sort of slave simply
for having my opinions.
Making it seem like I can't think
for myself because I am black.
Not understanding that
they're perpetuating
the exact same racism that they think
they're fighting against
by calling me those words.
- I'm from Thousand Oaks,
California and I've met people who
are like pretty hardcore conservatives.
I feel like all of us,
when we, my friends,
when we come and have these discussions,
we all just want what's
best for this country.
And of course we all have our own ideas
of how to achieve that,
but in the end we want
a world that's everyone
can benefit from.
And of course, unless you are able
to discuss with other people
your different opinions
with things and talk about the reasons
why you believe certain ways
you can't make any progress
with our country.
- I strongly agree.
And so personally, I'm from New Jersey,
you can probably figure out,
I have a predominantly
left-leaning friend group.
I never really took
issue with that cuz it's,
I feel like at the end
of the day you shouldn't
be exclusively talking about
politics with the people
you're friends with.
Especially, it's concerning to me that,
you know, based on recent studies,
a growing plurality of Americans
simply refuse to be friends
with people who are of
different political affiliations
from them.
That if anything, says
very concerning things
about our country.
Especially because you
know that this level
of political polarization
that we're seeing
now hasn't been matched
in American history
since the Antebellum era of the Civil War.
(applauding)
(group talking inaudibly)
(dramatic music)